Film Courage: Kaia, if someone has been on
one career path or has had one life calling
and they decide they want to change
course, what's your advice to them?
Kaia Alexander, CEO/founder of the Entertainment
Business School/Podcast Host/ Author: We saw so
many people in the pandemic realize life is short
and you've got to follow your passion, you've got
to do what you love, you've got to do what lights
you up. A lot of folks have circled back to What
is my calling? What was in my heart when I was a
teenager and in my 20s, maybe I gave up that path?
Then certainly the young people who maybe feel
even more ambitious than ever about I don't want
to compromise. I want to go after what really is
important to me. My best advice is to take every
advantage that you can give yourself going into
the entertainment business, going into Hollywood.
My own personal regret being Oh, I wish I
went to law school. I was a development exact
but oh my gosh had I gone to law school
and had some comprehension of contracts
going in, I would have been so much better
positioned. Those types of decisions Okay,
this is my calling. I really want to work
above the line writer, director, showrunner,
producer. How could you arm yourself? What
advantages could you give yourself? Living in
Los Angeles is an advantage. Living in New York is
an advantage. Making sure you have a great Wi-Fi
connection in your house so that your Zoom calls
don't drop off if you're taking meetings outside
the business because we have opened up virtually
now to folks who are not living in the major
epicenters of the industry. Looking at your life
that way. How could I give myself more advantages?
One of the biggest advantages you can think
about giving yourself is what I call finding
your WolfPack. Who are the others who could
partner with you who you just you love to
breathe their air, they excite you creatively.
Maybe you admire their writing or you admire
they're filmmaking or just somebody that makes you
laugh and you get along with them and like oh my
gosh they just always crack me up great partner
with them what could you work on together maybe
you could even do a short film together work
on getting a feature together that is something
that the industry always relates to and responds
to oh partnership this team of people are doing
this and when there's an energy around it that
can be a big draw especially for buyers who go
oh that's interesting producer goes this has some
momentum and that can really help you those types
of advantages what is reframing failure and how
have you implemented this in your life failure is
a topic that up until recent times has just really
been taboo you might feel ashamed you've had
some failures and you don't want to admit that to
anyone or maybe your family has even come down on
you like oh we expected better from you so then we
internalize those voices and then we can even turn
against ourselves so how do you reframe failure
well it's important to realize that all the most
successful people whether you're talking about
Elon Musk or Michael Jordan or Margaret Atwood
they have had significant failures in their lives
and in their past that has built their character
built their drive taught them oh I shouldn't go
that way I should go this way I get better results
if I do that and then so normalizing failure
for us oh it's an experiment for myself even
in my business or in my own writing I always
say this is an experiment then it's like oh
if it completely burns to the ground okay well
that experiment didn't work out let's try a new
experiment so it lowers the pressure doesn't have
to just be a success and knock it out of the park
all the time because then that ends up becoming
a burden of pressure that you put on yourself
so that's one way that I recommend navigating
failures through your own self talk this is an
experiment I'm going to try this I'm going to
try that and then it can be playful and fun the
entertainment industry really loves people who are
bringing in joy and fun and a sense of what I call
in the entertainment business school awesomeness
just be awesome bring awesomeness and then people
go what's happening over there with you and they
want to get to know you because you bring in your
best self your best spirit but failure is part of
the business across the board there are failures I
mean when I was a development exec we had movies
that didn't do well at the box office and we had
to process that and go okay well if we if we
invested in that we all believed in that and
it didn't work out what can we learn from that
so we can make a better decision next time and
we would have those debrief meetings so if there's
anyone in your life that you can debrief with who
you trust who is part of your wolf pack who
could say let's let's reframe the failure for
yourself as something that you learned that is
a mistake you won't make again so that you can
get the lesson and then make a different mistake
next time because I think the biggest failure that
any of us could have is making the same mistake
over and over that's the kind of truest failure
but if you actually make a mistake things go
sideways you learn from it then you get to
make a new mistake next time and then you can
start to feel like your own growth as a human
being is tied to your creative path and I think
that that's the best any of us can hope for it's
important to remember Leonardo da Vinci was not
famous in his lifetime he was passed over for the
cinee chapel he was a gay man who was imprisoned
for sodomy who couldn't even live his best life
out in public and he was discovered hundred years
after he died so I'm a historian and if you look
back through history you go oh my gosh there
are so many incredible examples of artists who
were recognized long after they passed because
they left Legacy they left something of value so
if you have decided this is my call in this is my
path stay really close to your Muse to your inner
voice that says how can I be give something
back how can I give something back to others
to the world through my art and you kind of have
to let it go knowing one of my producing partner
says it's better to have too many babies than
a spoiled baby so you don't necessarily get to
know oh I hope this project goes but you don't
really know if it will go you can hope and hope
and pray but if you a few projects then you have
more of a chance of knowing okay that one failed
that one failed oh but this one did really well
well you had said too that someone gave you the
advice that the entertainment industry loves
people who are busy pretty and forgive me I
forgot the other one happy busy pretty okay happy
busy pretty what if someone says well that's not
in my nature how can we sort of present that even
though once they get to know us they find out we
actually do great work so that's a quote that's a
little out of context let me give you the context
my friend Juliet Landau and I are always joking
about and laughing that this industry only wants
you to look happy busy and pretty all day every
day you can't let any of the warts show and that's
not human but yet if you go back through film
history it's glamour and it's optics and it's
image and all these things so there's a lot of
challenges to living in our modern times today
but one of the beautiful maybe silver linings
to all the challenges that we face is that we
do get to be a bit more real and I think we're all
craving feeling like someone is real think about
the show that you watched most recently that you
really really loved there's probably a character
from that show that was real that somehow whether
they were funny or more dramatic they felt so real
to you and alive and like someone you might even
want to be friends with and I think at the end of
the to day that's what we're all craving that's
what execs are craving that's what showrunners
want to staff in their rooms you might be watching
Star Trek and it's completely it's genre and it's
sci-fi and it's other worlds but then you realize
oh but I love do [Dr.] Crusher I love Picard these
are people who I wish I could know in real life
and because there's resonance because it feels
real audiences tune in that's what we want we want
to feel something we want to laugh we want to cry
we want to connect so being happy busy pretty even
though this industry is like we just want you to
do that it actually is full of real people execs
are real people they're like tell me your story
what do you want me to know about you and this
is what really will help you in your career is
getting in touch with your realness who are
you that you can really bring forward go to
the depths we say like right from your marrow if
if an actor is really embodied they're bringing
something real it's not just gloss and I think
that's what audiences crave long for want to
connect with we're wanting to get past the the
foe image and get to something deeper and real
think about a hit like the the bear which was
almost a little bit of a sleeper hit like they
didn't have a huge budget at the beginning in
their first season but by season two so much
realness the audiences are going oh my God this
is writing is incredible and I feel like I know
these people and I want to know these people and
they really penetrated a much bigger audience I
think for that quality that they were bringing
through the screen and if using that example
again this is not a show about happy busy and
pretty this is a show about real about here's
the scars here's the wounds here's the crazy
relationships and we're all I think longing for
that coming out of a horrific pandemic and then
in the entertainment business the strikes and
the work stoppages which were also painful for so
many of us and for my students as well that we're
all going how can we build something better how
can we build something that feels more real to
all of us that's more fun hopefully if you're
being fake you're not having fun that's just
the truth of it but if you're being real you're
going to make real connections real connections
with your own Wolfpack and also with your audience
and as you grow your career that's who you want to
have in the ripple effect of your creative works
is like oh the audience who I have fans and they
love what I did an example I use and teach from
in the entertainment business school is Mystery
Science Theater 3000 and Joel Hodson and I grew
up in my teen years watching these silly robots
and this ventriloquist make jokes about these be
movies and we would just laugh and laugh and he
de developed such a huge fan base that people who
are like oh we love him it's so creative it's so
real it's so funny and you would never expect
like an exec if you were pitching I'm going to
pitch you a show with a ventriloquist and a couple
of robots and we're going to make jokes about be
movies I don't know many exacts who would be like
oh yeah let's greenlight that but that when he's
coming from that real place that Joel Hudson
was as a creator huge fan base real connection.